cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com I want to jump to the story
from CNN Dallas mayor switches parties
to join GOP all right we just covered a
story about a Democrat being accused
taking bribes being corrupt and uh I
think for most of you who watch our show
you probably don't have a very favorable
view of Democrats nor the majority of
the Republican Party
but the Democrats I widely view as
corrupt tribalists who are just career
politicians who are trying to extract
what they can from the system and so
here you have this guy this is Dallas
mayor Eric Johnson responding to
questions during a news conference and
there are two issues that are brought up
because of this let me read a little bit
Dallas mayor Eric Johnson announced
Friday that he's switching parties and
will serve as a republican Affiliated
mayor of the blue leaning City while the
Dallas mayoral office is nonpartisan
Johnson previously served as a democrat
in the Texas legislature he slammed his
former party in an op-ed for the Wall
Street Journal published Friday blaming
Democratic policies for exacerbated
crime and homelessness quote the future
of America's great Urban centers depends
on the willingness of the nation's
Mayors to Champion Law and Order and
practice fiscal conservatism our cities
desperately need the genuine commitments
to these principles as opposed to the
inconsistent poll driven commitment of
many Democrats that has long been a
defining characteristic of the GOP so to
clarify
the mayoral position is not a partisan
position so they usually don't say like
the mayor's affiliation but he is he he
was a Democrat he ran you know in in in
this style this affiliation now he's
saying he is going to be joining the GOP
and will be Republican affiliate as
mayor
the question I have is first
if someone is a is a in a Democrat city
as as a high-level politician and
they're going to switch to the GOP
either they're saying I'm retiring or
they believe this is their their path to
maintaining their position and serving
their constituents secondly
this is a black mayor in a Democrat City
saying he's going to vote Republican and
we have more polling coming out from the
Wall Street Journal uh published in the
western journal and several other
outlets showing that Trump is pulling
very very well among Black and Hispanic
Americans I'm wondering if this is
Indica if this is a component of this as
well if this is an another individual
who is pulled and it's outright saying
no more Democrat now a republican I have
a feeling that this is that the
conditions at the border are a
significant factor in why the Dallas
mayor is switching sides I I can't see I
can't imagine that the people of Texas
who are the most immediately affected by
the the Border crisis I can't see them
saying Oh it's fine I can't see them
saying Oh it's no big deal these people
that live in Texas like they know they
have friends that are in the in the
Border region and stuff like that
I mean granted Texas is a big state but
still like these people are living with
it every day and you see videos all the
time of of Caravans of people coming to
the Border I just read a a piece that
said 300 there was a there was a a
record that 300 000 people cross the
border or were uh detained or
apprehended maybe is the best word uh
300 000 people in one month it's a
record I mean the federal government is
totally
abdicated their responsibility with that
of of securing the border the the clown
Administration that we have put Kamala
Harris in charge and she hasn't done
anything at all they tried to deal with
the uh the the dude what's his name not
Mendes
um he was just on Capitol Hill talking
to the uh talking to Congress
uh they had a Homeland Security either
way talking to him there's talk about
about impeaching him I think his name is
Americus yeah talking about impeaching
him and I don't know if anything's been
done but he has not done his job I I
think I here's how I see it there's that
Meme that I've brought up where it said
no one is trying to solve the problems
they're trying to get yeah Rich enough
to where the problems don't affect them
and I'm like that's a great motto for
the modern democratic party oh yeah help
us get rich enough so that your problems
are no longer our problems I wonder like
the problems affecting you won't affect
us is a better way to put it I wonder
what this means for 2024 because
obviously if you know anything about
Texas and the reason why people are
scared it's quote unquote going blue is
two major population growths it's in
Austin and Dallas right and so if you're
starting to see like Tim said is a
possibility which is he's actually maybe
doing it for a political reason because
he believes that the city of Dallas is
going to become more right-wing I could
see that translating to the rest of the
country too and I do think you're not
going to see demo Democrats do as well
in big cities as they did in 2020
because crime homelessness illegal
immigration all of it's adding up so I
wonder if there's something of an urban
a new Urban appeal for the Republican
party not to obviously win a majority of
any of these cities but at least to
crack you know I'm sure the Democrats
need a certain quota that way they can
outnumber the rural areas of a state
like Texas or Georgia or even Michigan
up in the Midwest states like that so I
wonder what it means for 2024 yeah I
really do the toxic compassion route has
failed them that's for sure like it
bringev's many people unlimited more
more more people more people more people
then also you realize you're surrounded
by homeless people that that don't have
food there and you know it's interesting
I'm from Los Angeles you know most of
the family friends and stuff we grew up
with are Democrat but
I'm noticing a very real Trend in the
people I knew growing up now trending
I'd say more independent maybe moderate
maybe some even just have flat out
become Republicans because they're just
seeing it's too expensive crime you know
it's it's dangerous homelessness
everywhere we just can't do this anymore
so like I said I'm not going to sell
anyone here at delusion that oh my gosh
Republicans are going to suddenly flip
LA or California but like I said in
swing states where the big city is our
problem I think a few points off of
popularity for the Democrats could make
the difference in one of these states
you know in the presidential election I
don't know if uh the immigration would
be as heavy as it is without the
internet I don't know if the internet's
played a part in allowing this to happen
or if it's just allowed us to see what's
happening because I think if this had
happened without an internet it would be
happening without us knowing and then
all of a sudden one day we'd wake up and
there would be six 60 million people
from foreign countries in our country we
wouldn't know and they'd already be here
yeah controlling things now we can kind
of see it in real time and adjust and
maybe help prevent a catastrophe yeah
and I think people are willing to alter
their political parties at the very
least if that if they feel like that
might make a difference or maybe just
sit home you know I think that's another
issue you talk about black turnout I'm
not I don't think Republicans are going
to come close to winning a majority of
the black vote but I think a lot of
these people who they normally bust to
the polls and all that in the inner
cities might just say uh I don't really
care for this right now you know what I
mean
um so I think you could see that too
just a drop off and turn out of their
base even if it's not for us right right
right I think that's actually what the
polls uh show yeah that I should clarify
there are there are polls showing
conserve is improving but I think what
you actually see when you look at the
bigger picture is that this
Effectiveness yeah support for Democrats
is way down and support Republicans a
little bit right so there are some
people are like I'm gonna vote for the
other guy but most people are just
saying I am not voting Democrat there's
no fuel there's no fuel like people
didn't vote for Biden they voted against
Trump right right he's not the president
right now the president's Biden so if
you're feeling like life sucks right now
you got to look at president buy and be
like he's not the guy anybody but him so
it may not be pro-trump people but
they're just like you're like like you
said they might just stay home they
might not go out and vote they're like I
can't vote for Trump but I'm not voting
for Biden and think about all the people
who you probably know people like this
that say if it's Trump versus Biden I'm
just going to leave that blank yeah that
helps Trump because Trump has a base in
Biden doesn't less so so yeah not only
has a base but he has disinfected
liberals yeah he there are a lot of
people who don't like Trump who will
vote for him because Trump's personality
issues and ego is nothing compared to
Biden's failures with the economy
foreign policy failures
Eastern European War these are these are
all just apocalyptic failures for our
president it's true it's and it's I mean
it is possible that he and Hunter Joe
Biden Hunter Biden got us into this war
in the Middle East obviously Russia you
mean Ukraine yeah I called it the Middle
East
and it's all kind of one area you know
Turkey is turkey the Middle East it's
right next the Middle East of Europe
yeah
um and it's like if they went there and
did some if Hunter went there and then
got bribed to be go on an energy board
for Prisma and they were and then Biden
just was like yeah let's make some money
off this and then we got into a war like
that's the most true maybe not treason
maybe not treason but like what's
selling out the country for sending the
country into a war to make profit I
think it would be treason
but I guess treason is specifically
providing Aid to a foreign adversary in
time of War I think that I don't think
that it's that personal like I don't
think when it comes to the war in
Ukraine I think that there's a whole
apparatus that is interested in seeing
Russia uh you know hurt and seeing uh
well actually just mostly Russia hurt I
think the the support from Ukraine comes
from the United States saying it is
better for our foreign policy to have a
weaker Russia so when Russia decided
they wanted to attack Ukraine or invade
Ukraine the U.S said we will help
Ukraine we will keep feeding them arms
and essentially it's the same model
that you know you we used or the US used
when there were the Russians were in
Afghanistan right so you were feeding
arms and ammunition and money to the
mujahideen and they were fighting
Russians so that way the Russians would
feel the same pain that the U.S felt
when the U.S was in Vietnam fighting the
VC and that was being funded by the
Russians in the Chinese this is the kind
of thing that happens or has happened uh
regularly since the end of World War II
because the Russians in the united or
the US and Russia can't get into an
actual confrontation themselves because
it'll likely turn into a nuclear war
these kind of uh
military actions are horrible and you
see you know war crimes are being posted
on X every day I just saw one there's a
dude trying to surrender to a drone and
they keep dropping bombs on him because
well he's the bad guy well that's a war
crime if he's trying to surrender and
they keep dropping hand grenades on him
kill him that's a war crime and you see
this stuff all the time and it's normal
in these kind of uh well it's normal in
war and it's it really does benefit the
U.S
strategically to have Russia engaged in
a war and have Russia weakened by you
know having a bunch of people die it's
gotten so dark Phil like I'll watch
these videos and you see the people
gathered around the tablet flying this
drone and they're laughing because
they're disconnected from the Carnage
and the chaos they're causing to be fair
though if you're if if someone invades
the United States all bets are off sure
you know if someone invades your country
like war crimes are for like people that
are in like in the U.S when they were in
World War II had to worry about war
crimes when they were in France right
nobody was looking at the French saying
you're committing war crimes because you
you know you're cutting Nazi's heads off
or whatever well the Nazis invaded you
know that's what happens and that's what
tends to happen in war generally but it
doesn't make it you know doesn't make it
any less of a war crime thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time